Jim called me might want to pull the
plug on that book tour now that the
former investigator himself is under
investigation Fox News has confirmed
that the Justice Department's inspector
general is investigating commis handling
of his memos describing his meetings
with President Trump a source saying
that the DOJ z' watchdog is looking into
whether the former FBI director leaked
any classified information let's get
into the details with attorney Tom
Dupree who served as principal Deputy
Assistant Attorney General and the
George W Bush administration plus
Republican Ron De Santis who joins us
from Florida tonight and Stephen Mulroy
a former federal prosecutor gentlemen
it's great to see all of you Steven
let's start with you here Jim Comey as
former FBI director perhaps thought that
look I'm the FBI director I can declare
what's classified and declare what's not
classified and so if I shoot these memos
over to pal at mine at Columbia Law
School no big deal he'll get into the
press and it'll cause a big stir and
maybe my reputation will be bolstered
maybe I'll even start a special counsel
but you know what doesn't this mean that
you know you know Comey could be in hot
water now with this with this new
investigation I'm not sure that's really
the case Laura it's important to
remember what exactly what we know here
we won't know for sure until the
inspector general has concluded its
investigation about what all the facts
are for sure but the Wall Street Journal
has reported that there were only two
memos that Comey gave to his friend that
had any classified information in one of
them he went through and redacted out
the classified information and the other
one wasn't classified at the time it was
only classified later on so it seems
like his course of conduct here was
fairly anodyne fairly inoffensive you
can't very well blame him if the
document wasn't classified until a later
point in time that kind of retroactive
liability I think he could argue is is
unfair well Tom Dupree is a self
redaction legit here he can
and redact look I'm sending it to my pal
who's gonna get it to the press or I'm
gonna read it I'm gonna get my big
sharpie I have a Sharpie here I'm gonna
get my big sharpie and black out some
foreign Intel names yeah Lorelai I think
even Jim Comey's defenders would admit
that he is walking a very fine line here
you know if the difference between
criminal jeopardy and innocence is where
you draw the line at the sharpie I mean
my goodness I wouldn't want to be in Jim
Comey's shoes if the IG is digging into
these memos line by line trying to see
whether or not he might have left
something in that shouldn't have gone
out the door the inspector general had
no patience for Andrew McCabe
clearly the lies from Andy McCabe I mean
he's in real trouble here and we'll see
if he has actually has any criminal
jeopardy there but congressman De Santis
let's remember what Jim Comey said back
in June of last year when he was
testifying on Capitol Hill about why he
decided to transmit those memos to his
friend he and I think we have Assad
let's watch and my judgment was I needed
to get that out into the public square
and so I asked a friend of mine to share
the content of the memo with a reporter
didn't do it myself for a variety of
reasons by asked him to because I
thought that might prompt the
appointment of a special counsel for a
variety of reasons congressman for a
variety of reasons he also self redacted
at least one of the two memos well it's
important to point out that that was
malicious linking leaking of government
documents I asked Christopher Rea under
oath is it appropriate for FBI agents to
leak their work product to the press and
he said absolutely not I do think he's
facing exposure because some of that
stuff very well may have been classified
but at the end of the day this is a guy
who took those documents he wanted to
generate a special counsel and it's
interesting you look at those memos he
actually writes down in the memos I told
the president I don't leak the fact that
he's writing that in the memo that he
doesn't leak tells me he probably was a
habitual leaker actually you bring up a
great point congressman and Steve will
go to you on this this is from the Comey
memo this is from January 6 right after
his first meeting at Trump Tower with
the president he said and he wrote I
said I was eager to find leakers and
would like to nail
to the door as a message that's very
dramatic I said something about it being
difficult and he replied that we need to
create a narrative that we were
investigating him of course because we
are not and I worried such a thing would
be misconstrued
but he kept as Ron said as congressman
to Santa said he went out of his way a
number of times to say to say to the
president he said he claims in this memo
to the file that well I'm not a leaker
you know you can trust Andrew McCabe
he's a stand-up guy and I don't leak and
McCabe is here is is in your corner
memos to the file are written by people
to do what Steve to do what I think
probably probably to memorialize a
conversation so that there can be no
doubt later on if it comes up what
exactly was said in what wasn't said I
think this course of conduct shows that
Comey was a bit concerned about a
potential obstruction of justice he knew
that there was a big controversy about
it he knew that it might become
important later on to know exactly what
was said and wasn't said and so we
wanted to contemporaneously document it
so On January 6 he was worried about
obstruction of justice well I think
quite possibly if you take a look at his
whole course of going up to me his way
to do it out of his way to be damned if
you think he is obstructing justice and
you're like sitting there and he's like
well I'm looking forward to staying on
with you and I'm looking forward to you
know he was he said what are your plans
he's like I enjoy my job I'd like to
stay on so that's why Molly Hemingway
today and others wrote that this whole
thing smells like a big setup the whole
meeting they're talking about the
dossier to rattle trump or try to rattle
them this well we don't know if it's
true but there's this thing and it looks
like they're saying this Tom you react
yeah you know it is puzzling I mean you
know the administration is just getting
started and already the FBI director is
you know memorializing for whatever his
purpose is works well you don't
memorialize to make yourself look bad
you memorialize yourself to make you
look good and I mean sorry yeah no I
think that's fair I think that's fair
and look this is exceedingly unusual I
mean I can't imagine any other
administration where a few days in you
have someone feeling the need to create
this sort of record so there's unusual
things going on here
congressman De Santis in there's a Comey
point in these
in these memos that talked about CNN I
want to read it he says I said media
like CNN had them the memos and we're
looking for a news hook I said it was
important that we not give them the
excuse to write that the FBI has the
material or that's redacted and that we
were keeping it very close hold he said
he couldn't believe they hadn't gone
with it and I said it was inflammatory
stuff and they would get killed for
reporting straight up from source
reports and then bingo just a few days
later
congressman de santis CNN runs with it
then it gets published elsewhere this is
why people were saying again the way
this is written this memo to the file
I said CNN it would be crazy to put I
don't know if you're right in the novel
here oh yeah and there's a CNN Headline
until cheese presented Trump with claims
Russian efforts to compromise him I mean
where do they get that from where did
that line from well just think about Jim
Comey this is a guy he never
memorialized any conversation with
Barack Obama he never did with Loretta
Lynch even though he now says Loretta
Lynch was conflicted it was only from
day one with Donald Trump so that
meeting to me is very fishy because Jim
clapper I and most of my Republican
colleagues believe is the one that
actually leaked the existence of the
meeting of CNN but why would tell me
that how do you know why do you think
that based off the intelligence
committee what they were able to come up
with and they allude to it in their
report but that's just the inference I
make I think he would he was the guy now
here's the deal
Comey acknowledges that it's not
newsworthy at the time they needed a
hook so what does he do he gives them
the hook so either he him and clapper
knew this together or maybe he was
acting a clapper suggestion yeah but he
provided the hook for that to go out and
when he's briefing Donald Trump on it he
only talks about the one salacious
allegation he didn't discuss other
aspects of the dossier don't you think
that's something the president-elect
should have been entitled to know about
and yet Comey hid that from him this
thing smells very badly
and I think he's gonna have to answer
more questions about he has to come back
to Capitol Hill does he not Steve I
think the point that congressman de
santis is making is when you go out of
your way to bring up the dossier and you
bring only basically one of the most
inflammatory elements of the dossier em
that's like that's rocket fuel to
someone like some like what like that in
you know you don't bring there's a lot
of other stuff in the dossier you bring
up that one point and we know now in
hindsight that he was using that
professor at Columbia - then get
information out to the press so he had
it in his mind a couple months later to
disseminate stuff to the press he wanted
to get out there he wanted a special
counsel appointed so why wouldn't it be
logical now to think huh maybe he and
clapper chatted about this said you know
we got to get this out this Trump's
workshop you know a person is set up
artist is another person's you know
whistleblower I mean here's a lifelong
Republican it was a promoted by
Republican presidents and who's handling
of the Clinton email investigation at
least as public handling of it arguably
was very much to Clinton's detriment
Clanker benefit so the idea that he's
got a motive - I'm not sure that he has
got the motive to do this setup job that
we're speculating got off scot-free in
this email investigation the Clinton
Foundation investigation was totally
Scotch tulta mately so the idea that he
let him that he liked helped Hillary I
never bought that argument Hillary
Clinton if anyone had ordinarily him
right now she were anyone else we'd
ordinarily what I'm suggesting is that a
prosecutor would just simply announced
we're not bringing charges he wouldn't
go on to say but she was extremely
reckless and then a week before the
election she was brought back up again
well I'm not sure I think you can make
an argument that a much diplomatic
conduct doesn't show a pro pro Clinton
bias if anything it shows that he was
not pro Clinton all right Tom look I see
this as Call Me has has shown us that he
if he wants to get information to the
press he'll figure out a way to do it
now that was a couple months later he
hated Donald Trump today he said on an
interviewer yesterday Oh
no I don't hate him I don't even dislike
him oh please he walked into that Trump
Tower meeting everything about Trump he
despises the way he dresses the way he
speaks he just probably doesn't think
he's as educated as he is he has utter
disdain for Trump
he's a butchery Paul I know you're a
butcher puppy's a Bush Republican but
not like a lot of Bush Republicans I
know he's condescending supercilious and
priggish and he can't stand Trump
because Trump's Trump's a different type
of guy and frankly kind of guy people
vote for well here's the thing I mean
one of the many tragedies I think here
Laura is that historically historically
the reason why the FBI has been held in
such esteem by the American public is
they have widely been viewed as a
nonpartisan independent law-enforcement
agency and what Jim Comey is doing now I
think undercuts that because what it is
is it's portraying a former FBI director
as a partisan actor as someone who has a
political axe to grind he's going on the
talk shows he's taking personal jabs at
the president and it may be very
satisfying to him and to people who
don't like the president but for
purposes of the American people's
perception of the FBI I think it
deserves the institution frankly